enjoy it otherwise just second enough to
what you said actually about the whole
going out with your friends
that's your friend's intention I think
you need to know your friend I'm not
saying you don't know I'm not coming at
you at all like that but I would say I
think you need to know your friends I
think to be honest with you if I I
wouldn't go out with a group of girls
and there are 10 I mean none of my
friends are like that none of my friends
I mean I'm speaking generally yeah 90 of
my friends are in long-term relations
and they're also like yeah and that's
fine and I'm not and I wasn't speaking
about you directly I'm just talking
about generally speaking sometimes
because we see it you go out and
sometimes girls you see other girls
leave their friends I don't understand
that mindset because for me me and my
circle we're one if we go left we all go
left no one's getting left home no one's
going home with no guys that's not how
we operate so for me I can go out with
single girls to wherever because we're
going out to have a good time yes if my
single friend gets approached by a guy
she might get approached by a guy they
may swap numbers but at the end of the
night she's not leaving me like she's
not knowing me that's your specific
friend yeah your engagement with your
partner whatever and and the trust and
the like the
conversations that you guys have had and
how you know each other but not everyone
is like 100 but that's why I said I
think it depends when we're saying
obviously about girls going out to clubs
if you're in a relationship single I
think it depends on who your single
friends are yeah and I think we can
probably all say we've probably seen
situation you're thinking I would never
go out with you because you leaving on
my own and you put me in a situation
that's what I'm saying like I think it
really does depend on your circle and
who you move with definitely yeah I want
to add something
um
what Andrew Tate said was interesting
just about the point where he was
basically explaining like oh I want my
woman to be doing X Y and Z and you know
I don't want a woman that's going to
question that and I think
with women I feel like
can men just apply you see I feel like
with men they set expectations and
whether you live up to it you live up to
it if you don't you don't but I feel
like with women women don't like they
have a certain set of expectation but
it's like sometimes you would get with a
guy who like let's say doesn't
necessarily meet your full criteria but
women will then be like right but then
maybe I can change him in this sort of
element and it's like
when you see how do I make this without
linking back to the point and it's like
Andrew women are complaining like why is
Andrew T not letting his girlfriends out
no he's just set himself a standard and
that's what we expect same way as a
woman if I want a man to take me out on
a date I would require you to pay for me
but some women don't and it's like like
you said I think it's a mixture of what
you want from your partner and I do see
it like it can be disrespectful because
a club is really just to socialize me go
out and meet new people but it's like
why are you meeting new men for when you
have like a boyfriend because it's not
on a friendship level let's be realistic
when alcohol is in your system and
I feel like
but how do I how I'm I'm so sorry I
understand what you're saying I I just
because it's not like you're going there
to make Pals and the guys that are
approaching you aren't there to be your
friend and so you're it's like you're
putting yourself in a situation yeah and
it's like with certain friends like I
don't know about me I'm gonna speak from
an experience because I think that's I'm
better at describing certain situations
for experiences and it's like I can be
out with a group of friends and they all
have a motive on meeting and like new
guys and now they've approached us to go
to a table and you know these guys when
they invite you to a table they expect
something and it's like even as a single
friend there by me going there I still
have to put on some sort of act I need
to respond to be I need to be nice
because if I'm a [ __ ] a lot of the time
some guys can still be like well your
friend's not doing anything and I feel
like friends can peer pressure you
friends could be like well a little bit
of flirting is not gonna hurt how many
times have you heard some people be like
flirting is not that deep but the
question is now when I'm flirting with
you and there's alcohol in my system and
I'm angry at you because you've pissed
me off this morning
now what's going to happen now when I
indulge into this conversation and now
I'm feeling like this guy is everything
I've wanted it can actually lead to
cheating how many people go out and
regret after a night out of drinking
that they've cheated on their partner
but wouldn't have done it put yourself
in that situation where you're with
single friends and you're drinking
alcohol which you know like can induce
that sort of behavior like I don't I
wouldn't put myself in that situation
because
I don't trust other people and you know
anything at people the the like nature
that these days of people's drinks
getting spiked and things like that
there's so much that can happen in those
situations and I just I don't I don't
think it's a sensible thing to do
personally
but obviously you know everyone I agree
and that's the point that I was trying
to make now that I've got it in my head
it's external factors I think Andrew is
not worried like he said about people
stealing his girls it's about external
factors you never know what can happen
to you whilst at you and the club and
it's out of your control and it's like
some men find it more safe if they're in
the club because they can watch over
their women and as a man and as
masculine man you are Territorial and I
think there's nothing wrong with it
because personally would I want a loads
of women flocking around my man and my
man just being nice for the sake of it
no so I feel like there shouldn't be a
problem you would appreciate it though
mm-hmm you would you would appreciate it
because your man's valued that that's
the only difference I would say if a lot
of women liked your man in some sense
you'll be like no but I'm saying how
he's acting towards them you see there's
a difference like you see now if I'm
he's at the club there's loads of women
they're all just flirting with him and
he's
kind of being disrespectful to the point
where like you are drawing lines because
if I was to do that well you can't even
let me out to go in the club by myself
but yet you that's just you being a
shitty person but I'm just speaking for
the people who do have clear intentions
and don't necessarily don't want their
girlfriend to go out to the club because
they just have one personal control it's
just about respect and boundaries and
whatever you're comfortable with you
agree to it I guess
yeah I agree I think that was a really
good point Sorry five voltage
I understood what you were saying
um we're gonna react to one more clip
um from Andrew Tate
um blessing do the one
that's
uh Andrew Tate exposes the truth behind
women cheating
then that's the last one we're gonna do
not that one do that one yeah
it involves emotion you will not sleep
with a man you don't like I can think of
women I don't like it's completely
different things I can be head over
heels in love with a woman ready to die
if they're ready to take a bullet for
our protect her and give her all the
money in the world make sure she has a
family a nice big house all of it and
I'll stick that watch me we will
infidelity involves emotion you will not
sleep with a man you don't like I can
see the woman I don't like completely
different things I can be head over
heels in love with a woman ready to die
if I'm ready to take a bullet for our
protectors give her all the money in the
world make sure she has a beautiful
family a nice big house all of it and
I'll still watch me
laughs
I feel like you got something that was
really so hard
I can't lie this this is probably one of
the few things I can't endorse him for
even if it's a it's a fact but again I
agree what you said delivery is
everything so to say it in that manner
there's no need but it's true I feel
when is he not doing his job by doing
that because his job his job is to earn
more like he's trying to earn more money
and get more views and the way that he's
saying that is gonna it's funny bring
more it's money that's going to bring I
can